monsieur logicien a deux enfants je lui
demande s'il a au moins un garçon il
répond oui comme on l'a vu dans des
épisodes précédents ceci devrait nous
pousser à mettre nos probabilités un
tiers sur le fait que les deux enfants
de monsieur logicien sont des garçons
maintenant je me demande s'il a au moins
un garçon né un mardi et il répond oui
hélas dans l'épisode 6 j'ai prétendu et
démontrer que la probabilité que les
deux enfants de monsieur logicien soit
des garçons est désormais égal à presque
un demi techniquement elle est égale à
13 27e et ça a priori ça devrait être
très perturbant pendant très longtemps
je savais prouver ce résultat
mathématiquement mais j'avais un mal fou
à comprendre pourquoi je connaissais la
preuve
mais je n'avais aucune intuition du
résultat en particulier
clairement je n'avais aucune intuition
bayésienne du résultat est
malheureusement pendant longtemps j'en
suis resté là je me suis contenté de
constater que mon intuition des
probabilités étaient ultra mauvaises
comme s'il s'agissait d'une fatalité
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est de vous
motiver à aller au delà de cette
fatalité et de vous fournir des clés
pour rendre le raisonnement bayésiens
partiellement intuitif on va chercher à
développer l'intuition bayésienne en
nous appuyant notamment sur le curseur
de turing dont on a parlé dans l'épisode
précédent en particulier
chirac à la fin de cet épisode vous
soyez capable d'avoir la bonne intuition
des énigmes suivante énigmes numéro un
monsieur logicien a deux enfants je lui
demande s'il a au moins un garçon il
répond oui je lui demande ensuite de
penser à un de ces garçons et de me dire
quel jour de la semaine ce garçon est né
il répond mardi
quelle est la probabilité que monsieur
logicien à deux garçons plutôt un tiers
plutôt un demi ou plutôt autres choses
encore énigme numéro 2 je joue au poker
contre monsieur logicien je lui demande
s'il a un as il répond oui je lui
demande ensuite s'il à l'as de pique
il répond oui est ce que cette deuxième
réponse oui est une bonne nouvelle pour
moi
ou est ce que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle ou est-ce que ça ne changera
rien alors je suis sûr que les matheux
parmi vous pourrez être posée les
équations et résoudre ces problèmes mais
ce n'est pas ce que je veux que vous
fassiez aujourd'hui j'aimerais que vous
essayez d'intuit et la réponse notamment
en développant un raisonnement
approximativement parisien pour arriver
à répondre à ces questions je vous
propose d'analyser un tout autre
problème
inspiré de cette superbe vidéo dit
mental imaginons deux d assise face sur
le premier des imaginons qu'il y ait
deux as et 4 b et sur le second cette
fois il y à deux baies et quatre à
mettre du jeu prend les deux des les
mélanges ont choisi un au hasard
puis il lance le dé et nous dise il est
tombé sur un as ou sur un b supposons
qu'il soit tombé sur un as qu'elle aime
désormais la probabilité qu'il s'agisse
du premier des pour répondre à cette
question je vous propose de reconsidérer
le curseur de turing dont on a parlé
dans l'épisode précédent
souvenez vous que ce curseur se trouve
sur une longue robe graduée avec un
milieu à l'extrême droite il y a le t1 à
extrême gauche il ya le d2 et la
position du curseur nous indique si l'on
croit plutôt que le d utiliser et le t1
où le d2 a priori les deux des sons
tirés au hasard
donc à priori ils sont est plus probable
du coup on peut placer pour commencer le
curseur de turing au milieu ce curseur
est donc à 0 bits sur la droite de
turing ensuite on apprend que le dé est
tombé sur un as intuitivement ce
résultat est plus compatible avec le d2
qu'avec le deun donc il faudra déplacer
le curseur vers la gauche
mais de combien de beats faut-il
déplacer ce curseur vers la gauche pour
répondre à cette question comme on l'a
déjà vu dans l'épisode 2 3 il nous faut
absolument faire des expériences de
pensée et à être sensibles à la surprise
des résultats dans ces expériences de
pensée
dans notre cas on a deux des donc deux
théories à considérer et donc nos
expériences de pensée à l'effectuer une
part d commençons par imaginer que ce
fut le premier dès qui fut tiré sur nous
alors surpris de voir un à apparaître
sommes-nous surpris par cette donnée
sachant qu'il y avait deux as et 4 b oui
on est quand même pas mal surpris pas
ultra surpris n'est pas mal surpris en
supposant que le dé est le premier des
la vraisemblance de la donner à est
égale à un tiers
quid de 6 et le second dès qu'ils aient
tiré se noue alors surpris qu'un à tombe
là cette fois vu qu'il y à quatre a et b
le résultat est peu surprenant pas
complètement sans surprise mais on
aurait pu s'y attendre
en fait le terme d' expérience de pensée
est égal
deux tiers en particulier ce qui faut
noter c'est que dans la première
expérience de pensée
la donnée est deux fois plus surprenante
que dans la seconde expérience de pensée
on dit que le rapport de surprises aussi
appelé rapport de vraisemblance ou
facteur de belize est égal à 2 hors
rapport de 2 c'est justement égal à 1
bit d'information
du coup la donne et nous forcent à
déplacer le curseur d'un beat dans la
direction de la théorie qui colle le
mieux aux données c'est-à-dire vers le
seconde et le curseur est désormais à un
beat en faveur du d2 voilà qui revient à
dire que le d2 est deux fois plus
crédible que le premier il a une cote de
2 contre 1
ce qui correspond à une crédence de 2 /
2 + 1 est égale à deux tiers ce qui est
vraiment cool maintenant c'est que ce
curseur de crédence peut continuer à
être déplacé au fur et à mesure que
davantage de données sont collectées
imaginons ainsi que le dé tirer par le
maître du jeu soient désormais lancé
plusieurs fois devenant successivement
des b à b à bbb a et b1 et avec le b qui
correspond donc au second lancer cette
fois on est deux fois plus surpris s'il
s'agit du d2 que s'il s'agit du t1
voilà qui nous force à déplacer le
curseur d'un beat vers la droite puis
avec le nouveau bébé encore un but vers
la droite le à nous fait faire un beat
vers la gauche qui ont fait un beat à
droite un beat à gauche trois bits
à droite un beat à gauche de beats à
droite un beat à gauche et enfin un beat
à droite
après tout ça on se retrouve 4 bits à
droite c'est à dire en faveur du des uns
et ça ça veut dire que le t1 est
désormais deux puissances 4 soit 16 fois
plus probable que le d2 il a une cote de
16 contre 1 ce qui correspond à une
crédence de 16 / 16 plus en quête égal à
16/17 et ça c'est environ 94% de
crédence
de façon plus générale ce que cet
exemple montre c'est que le curseur de
turing est donc la crédence est quelque
chose qui ne cesse de bouger
à chaque nouvelle donne et voilà qu'il
ya années et les heures ioukos qui a
parlé de danse des crédences en
particulier chaque pas de cette danse
est une petite modification des
crédences et ça en particulier c'est par
opposition à l'idée de la science par
réfutation qui consisterait à casser les
croyances d'un coup de massue mais bien
souvent il semble que l'apprentissage
soit davantage quelque chose de
relativement continue l'apprentissage
ressemble davantage à l'accumulation
d'un très grand nombre de petits pas
comme le dit le proverbe bayésiens
l'apprentissage est une danse il semble
que ce soit vraiment l'un des
enseignements importants du bail à nice
mme il faut constamment évalué et
réévalué ses créances c'est ainsi qu'on
apprend le mieux
oui car le truc important c'est que
l'addition de ces petites modifications
peut rapidement créer des énormes
bouleversements des crédences en effet
rapidement on peut arriver à plusieurs
bits à gauche ou à droite de la droite
de turing or être disons 10 bits à
gauche correspond à une cote de 2
puissances disent contraints soit 1000
contre 1
et pour peu qu'on en arrive à 30 ou 50
buts à gauche ce qui peut être obtenu
après seulement quelques centaines de
données et de pas de danse on obtient
alors des cotes astronomiquement en
faveur d'une théorie ou d'une autre
c'est à dire des crédences égal à 90 9 9
9 9 9 9 9 9 %
les petits pas de danse du curseur de
turing peuvent nous amener rapidement
très loin revenons en maintenant à
monsieur logicien comment réfléchir au
genre des enfants à l'aide de curseur de
turing a priori le problème c'est qu'on
a quatre théorie à considérer à savoir
garçon garçon garçon fille fille garçon
et fille fuit alors que le curseur de
turing ne permet d'opposer que deux
théories concurrentes
et bien pour ceux ramenés à seulement 2
théorie on peut appliquer deux astuces
la première consiste à ignorer le cafi
notamment parce qu'on peut anticiper que
sacré danse a posteriori c'est à dire
une fois qu'on a appris que monsieur
logicien à au moins un garçon sera égal
à zéro la seconde astuce consiste à
regrouper les cas garçons filles et 6
garçons en un cas un garçon et une fille
sans préciser l'ordre dans lequel ils
ont été obtenues on va ainsi comparer
les cotes entre des théories
concurrentes qui seront garçon garçon
est un garçon et une fille
notez par ailleurs que le fait qu'il
existe des alternatives à ces deux
théories ne nous empêche pas d'utiliser
le curseur de tueries pour mettre en
concurrence uniquement ces deux théories
et pour commencer bien sûr il faut
déterminer le préjugé adéquat à avoir a
priori
qu'est ce qui est plus crédible entre
garçons de garçon est un garçon et une
fille
et bien comme on l'a déjà vu et je vous
renvoie notamment vers la vidéo de
monsieur philippe pour plus
d'explications
a priori parce que un garçon et une
fille coassements à deux configurations
cette théorie est deux fois plus
probable que garçon garçon
du coup a priori on est à un beat du
côté de un garçon et une fille
ok maintenant on demande à monsieur
logicien s'il a au moins un garçon et là
il nous offre la donner oui faut-il
bouger le curseur de turing pour
déterminer comment déplacer le curseur
de turing il faut effectuer les deux
expériences de pensée qui correspondent
aux deux théories considéré or noté que
si on suppose car son garçon alors la
réponse oui de monsieur logicien n'est
absolument pas surprenante
on sait que c'est la réponse que doit
donner monsieur logicien et d'ailleurs
il en est de même si on suppose un
garçon et une fille
à la question avez vous au moins un
garçon dans cette seconde expérience de
pensée
on sait que monsieur le logicien doit
répondre oui
en fait on est là dans un cas où
l'information n'est absolument pas
surprenante dans aucune des théories
considérer si tel est le cas c'est que
le rapport de surprise est
nécessairement égal à 1
ce qui revient à dire qu'il ne faut pas
déplacer le curseur le curseur reste au
même endroit en fait il s'agit même là
d'un théorème en l'absence de surprise
seuls les préjugés permettent de
conclure
pensez-y la prochaine fois qu'un
individu à défendre à une position de
manière très prévisible si vous savez ce
qu'il va dire c'est que ce qu'il va dire
ne doit pas affecter ce que vous pensez
du cas si vous êtes payant al'inverse si
l'autre c'est exactement ce que vous
allez dire c'est que ça ne sert à rien
de le lui dire
en tout cas si l'autre est suffisamment
parisiens en particulier ici dans le cas
de monsieur logicien après sa réponse
oui à la première question ou conclu que
conformément aux préjugés
monsieur logicien a deux fois plus de
chance d'être dans le cas un garçon et
une fille que dans le cas car son garçon
on est à deux contre un pour le fait que
l'autre enfants de monsieur logicien
soit une fille soit une crédence de deux
divisée
de plus un qui est égale à deux tiers ok
maintenant qu'en est il de la réponse
oui à la question monsieur logicien at
il au moins un garçon né un mardi notez
qu'il s'agit d'une information
surprenante que l'on soit dans le cas
garçon garçon ou dans le cas un garçon
et une fille
en effet dans les deux cas monsieur
logicien aurait très bien pu répondre
non du coup cette fois il faut
s'attendre à peut-être devoir changer
notre curseur de turing pour savoir
comment le modifier il faut imaginer que
le curseur va fuir la théorie pour
laquelle l'information est la plus
surprenante en particulier il nous faut
donc nous poser de questions en
supposant garçon garçon l'information du
garçon né un mardi et elle surprenante
et surtout est elle plus surprenante en
supposant de garçon garçon quand
supposons un garçon et une fille en
particulier quel est le rapport de
surprises et bien en supposant un garçon
et une fille
c'est à dire en supposant que monsieur
logicien à exactement un garçon on peut
voir que l'information monsieur logicien
à au moins un garçon né à mardi est
assez surprenante et d'une chance sur 7
cependant en supposant garçon garçon
l'information monsieur logicien à au
moins un garçon venait un mardi est
alors moins surprenante
intuitivement les quasiment de deux
chances sur sept puisque chaque garçon
était un candidat pour être né un mardi
et qu'il y a deux garçons
bon comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode si ce
n'est pas exactement savent qu'il faut
faire gaffe à ne pas compter deux fois
le cas où les deux garçons sont nés un
mardi et du coup au lieu de 2 7e
la vraisemblance de la donner et est
égal à 13 49e
mais bon l'approximation 2/7 est
quasiment égal à 13 49e nous suffira
pour avoir une intuition de la bonne
réponse
on voit alors que la donne et monsieur
logicien à au moins un garçon né mardi
est presque deux fois moins surprenante
pour la théorie garçon garçon que pour
la théorie un garçon et une fille voilà
qui nous invite à déplacer le curseur de
presque un beat vers garçon garçon
on voit alors que l'on tombe quasiment
au milieu avec une cote qui reste très
légèrement en faveur de un garçon et une
fille
les théories garçon garçon est un garçon
et une fille sont alors quasiment est
plus probable elles ont quasiment décote
à un contre un en particulier comme en
plus dans ce cas on sait que seuls les
théories garçon garçon est un garçon et
une fille sont possibles on en déduit
que la crédence de la théorie garçon
garçon
quasiment égal à 1,2 me mets pas tout à
fait pour rappel la bonne réponse est
13e 27e soit vraiment quasiment un demi
on est bon
alors aujourd'hui j'ai appliqué cette
idée de curseur de turing nos problèmes
d'aidé et de l'enfant né un mardi je
vous invite vraiment à faire et refaire
le raisonnement chez vous pour mieux
sentir ces histoires de cotes de
préjugés et de rapports de surprises en
particulier je vous invite à prêter
davantage attention à la notion de
surprise dans l'expérience de pensée qui
est vraiment critique pour mettre à jour
les crédences de manière correcte et
bien sûr il faut aussi voir que les
problèmes qu'on a fêté aujourd'hui ne
sont que des exemples pour entraîner
notre intuition bayésienne le but de la
vidéo d'aujourd'hui et du reste de la
série de vidéos qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment n'est pas de mieux
réussir des exercices d'examen de maths
le but c'est vraiment de mieux réfléchir
à toutes sortes de problèmes y compris à
des cas ultra pratique en particulier je
vous invite à méditer comment tout ceci
ça pique
que ce soit à d'autres problèmes
théoriques comme les deux autres
problèmes que j'ai mentionné en début de
vidéo ou celui présenté par alexandre
techno prog dans cette vidéo ainsi qu'à
des problèmes beaucoup plus concret
voire même à des problèmes controversé
est politisée en particulier je vous
invite vivement à aller voir ses vidéos
d'hygiène mentale et d'alexandre techno
prog qui appliquent ce raisonnement
intuitif à d'autres problèmes beaucoup
plus importants que l'énigme des deux
enfants entraînez-vous notamment à
développer une intuition vraiment
bayésienne de ces problèmes c'est à dire
un coup de préjugés et de rapports de
surprises et pour cela en particulier il
me semble utile de beaucoup plus
valorisé la surprise qu'on ne le fait
actuellement
oui car malheureusement il arrive
souvent qu'on trouve cool le côté blasé
du mec qui savait déjà voir à penser que
le mec jamais surpris et quelqu'un de
plus crédible c'est fort dommage car ça
nous encourage à ne pas nous émerveiller
devant la surprise et à la partager
publiquement
or c'est cette surprise qui est crucial
pour se remettre en question pour
éveiller notre curiosité et donc aussi
pour déterminer comment déplacer le
curseur de crédence notre univers est
une formidable complexité prenons le
temps de le laisser nous surprendre l'un
fois j'avais introduit le curseur de
turing de manière théorique et notamment
la formule mathématique
ça correspond vraiment à quelque chose
de très belles heures donc s'il ya
vraiment un fondement à ce curseur de
de turing et je pense que c'est vraiment
très intéressant de faire le lien entre
ces formules mathématiques rigoureuse et
solide pour laquelle on peut prouver des
théorèmes très très réconfortant avec
l'intuition que l'on pourrait avoir de
la bonne manière de faire et en
particulier keep calm fait remarquer que
cette idée de curseur de turing parfois
appelée curseur de vraisemblance j'ai
souvent entendu ce mot notamment dans le
domaine de la zététique c'est quelque
chose que l'on sent intuitivement comme
étant la bonne façon de faire mais c'est
important de ramener ça à quelque chose
de mathématiques qui me semble pour
vraiment se dire qu en effet c'est la
bonne façon de faire
parce que l'intuition que l'on pourra
avoir de l'épistémologie est souvent
très problématique et on a souvent
tendance à croire des choses de manière
pas toujours très justifiées dix ans
alors j'en profite notamment pour au
monde hier sur la terminologie notamment
la notion de curseur de vraisemblance il
me semble être une terminologie très
problématique en tout cas si jamais vous
utiliser ce mot fait vraiment vraiment
attention au fait que les statisticiens
utilise le beauf récent lance dans un
sens différent de ce que vous entendez
par curseur de vraisemblance en
particulier pour un statisticien le mot
vraisemblance correspondra toujours
invraisemblances des données ça ne parle
jamais de la crédence de la théorie
vraisemblance des données n'est pas a
créé danse de la théorie c'est ultra
important de faire la distinction entre
les deux en termes mathématiques non le
langage des probabilités
le premier la notion de vrai sens des
données correspondent à la probabilité
des données sachant une théorie alors
que le second correspond à la craie dans
une théorie correspond à la probabilité
de la théorie sachant les données et ces
deux notions sont extrêmement ou très
différente c'est très très important de
faire la distinction entre les deux
joueurs voient notamment vers
l'excellente vidéo des jeunes mentale
qui fait très bien cette distinction et
on y viendra aussi dans cette série sur
la formule de bise et du coup sachant
qu'il ya vraiment énormément de
confusion entre vraisemblance des
données et créer dans des théories que
ce vraiment un des points importants de
béziers
c'est vraiment faire la distinction
entre les deux j'aurais tendance à tous
vous encourager de cesser d'utiliser la
notion de curseur de vraisemblance parce
que les biais psychologiques humains
font qu'on risque du coup de les
confondre avec la vraisemblance des
données
ce qu'on entende parler de maximum de
vraisemblance par exemple on va croire
que le maximum devrait sûrement c'est la
théorie la plus vraisemblable plus
crédible alors que non maximum de
vraisemblance et la théorie qui maximise
la vraisemblance des données c'est pas
du tout la théorie la plus crédible on
verra notamment des exemples client de
cela bref fait vraiment attention aux
mots que vous utilisez lorsque vous
parlez des probabilités
parce que si vous faites la confusion
selon certains mots c'est un risque
à vous de vous amener à faire la
confusion entre certaines bonne
interprétation des données à faire et du
coup à vous amener à avoir des
raisonnements qui sont faux d'un point
de vue bayésiens du coup j'aurais
tendance à vous encourager à parler de
curseur de crédence et pas deux curseurs
de vraisemblance
encore une fois la vraisemblance des
données n'est pas la crédence la théorie
et j'espère que vous avez mais cette
vidéo la préférence va appliquer le
curseur de turing un problème ultra
concret et ultra important à savoir
juger là le degré de validité d'une
publication scientifique
si vous aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue est allé commentaire partagé pour
ses abonnés pourront compter sur
l'épisode inertie est hyper perdons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois ma croyance en ce truc était de - 6
mai grâce à ce nouveau résultat si je
veux être rationnel je dois maintenant
la montée de deux crans et l'a placé à
moins 4 remarquez bien que j'y crois
toujours pas tony miserait pas un pour
dix mille là dessus mais mon opinion a
quand même évolué je suis un peu moins
sûre de moi un peu moins catégorique
ça m'a mis un peu le doute mais ça n'a
pas suffi à me faire passer la barre
symbolique des 50% le niveau zéro le
seuil à partir duquel je commencerai à
dire que j'y crois si demain dans une
conversation me présente un nouvel
argument ou une nouvelle preuve
genre une étude scientifique qui
tendrait à me prouver que j'ai tort
alors il faudra que je reprenne mon
curseur actuelle il devient mon nouvelle
a priori et j'y ajoute le niveau de
cette nouvelle preuve le rapport des
vraisemblances et si c'est une preuve de
niveau 7
alors -4 +7 égal 3 et là je serai
convaincu je reconnaîtrais que l'on a
réussi à me faire changer d'avis je
dirais maintenant j'y crois au niveau 3
je ne suis pas encore tout à fait
certain mais ça me paraît plutôt
plausible exemple has been increasing ma
maison
à